RICHES AND RICHES.
>> Tucker: THE ONLY WOMAN LISA
BLOOM IS HELPING IS LISA BLOOM.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> THANKS A LOT, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THE LATEST WAVE OF
NOW, AND HIS FORMER WIFE,
HUMA ABEDIN'S, A FORMER LAPTOP
HAS COME OFF.
FIVE MORE CLASSIFIED MESSAGES
ON THE LAPTOP.
TOM FITTON IS PRESIDENT OF
JUDICIAL WATCH, SECURED THE
RELEASE OF THESE.
TOM, HOW HARD IS IT TO GET
THESE?
>> IT ONLY TOOK TWO YEARS.
[LAUGHTER]
FEDERAL LAWSUIT.
THE FBI FOUND THESE RECORDS LAST
BACK IN OCTOBER WHEN JAMES KOBE
FAMOUSLY ANNOUNCED AT A PRESS
CONFERENCE THERE WERE OTHER
DOCUMENTS ON THE WEINER LAPTOP.
>> Tucker: RELEASE THE
PERSONAL PROPERTY OF HUMA ABEDIN
AND ANTHONY REEDER?
OR THEY      WITH A GOVERNMENT R
OR THEY      WITH A GOVERNMENT P
OR THEY      WITH A GOVERNMENT Y
OR THEY      WITH A GOVERNMENT ?
>> THEY DETERMINED THEY WERE
GOVERNMENT RECORDS AND THEY WERE
TURNED OVER TO THE
WAIT TWO YEARS TO GET THEM?
>> WE FOUND OUT ABOUT CLINTON'S
EMAIL SERVER BACK IN 2015,
FOUND SOME OF THE MORE
ADDITIONAL EMAILS ON THESE TO BE
WEINER LAPTOP BUT DIDN'T TAKE
SERIOUSLY ENOUGH TO PURSUE
CRIMINAL CHARGES AGAINST ABEDIN
OR CLINTON FOR ALLOWING THIS
EGREGIOUS ABUSE OF TRUST THAT
THEY HAD PLACED IN THEM FOR
IN WASHINGTON FOR A LONG TIME IN
PUBLIC CASES LIKE THIS FOR A
LONG TIME, GIVE US SOME
PERSPECTIVE.
IF YOU HAD THIS MANY CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS ON YOUR LAPTOP, WHAT
WITH THE CONSEQUENCES BE?
>> WELL, HE WOULD LOSE THEIR
SECURITY CLEARANCE ALMOST
INITIALLY, AND HE WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION AND PERHAPS
CLASSIFIED MATERIALS THAT WERE
FOUND IN THE CLINTON EMAIL
SERVER, BUT THERE WERE A HIGHLY
TOP-SECRET DOCUMENTS OF THE MOST
SECURE TYPE, AND IT WOULD HAVE
RESULTED IN CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION, I GUARANTEE YOU, IF
YOU OR ANYBODY ELSE.
4.5 MILLION PEOPLE WITH SECURITY
THE WAY HILLARY CLINTON AND
HUMA ABEDIN HAVE BEEN PROTECTED.
THIS IS WHY IT IS INTERESTING TO
SEE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, AS
REPORTED TODAY, IS ACTUALLY REAL
LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE FINALLY.
THE PRESSURE IS WORKING, TUCKER.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS GOING
LYNCH, HOW THEY HANDLE THIS LAST
YEAR, ABOUT THE DECISION TO
PROSECUTE AND THINGS LIKE THAT,
AND IS WELL PAST TIME THAT TOOK
PLACE.
>> Tucker: SO A SYSTEM THAT
CRUSHES ORDINARY PEOPLE PROTECTS
THE POWERFUL AND WELL-CONNECTED.
>> ABOUT IT.
RIGHT NOW, WE ARE FIGHTING OVER
WHETHER THEY ARE EVEN GOING TO
DO A DAMAGE ASSESSMENT OVER
HEAVEN CLASSIFIED MATERIAL, AS I